[Musik]
sabine beuke sozialarbeiterin
sie hilft alten menschen ein
selbstbestimmtes leben zu führen so
lange wie möglich auch wenn die
körperlichen und geistigen kräfte
schwinden
das macht angst machten wut verzweiflung
und pharmazie kümmert sich um familien
in denen häufig das wohl der kinder
gefährdet ist viel verantwortung für den
sozialarbeiter
[Musik]
menschen helfen die auf der
schattenseite der gesellschaft stehen
das ist die große aufgabe der sozialen
helfer
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sabine bürgel vom seniorenbüro süd des
sozialamts bochum auf dem weg zu einem
hausbesuch eine verwirrte senioren
braucht dringend hilfe
ihr zustand verschlechtert sich derzeit
rapide deshalb fährt sabine bürger
täglich zu ihr
andere fälle müssen jetzt warten haben
sie post bekommen vielleicht kommen noch
mal gucken wir warten ja im grunde
genommen auf ein schreiben von ihrer
pflegekasse macht können wir das mal das
ich ist das von das müssten wir einmal
gucken dass das gemacht wird da wohl die
gez geld und der adac hat ihnen auch
geschrieben das habe ich gestern gesehen
dass lag da ja aber der kann ja wir
müssen wenn du bescheid sagen dass sie
kein auto mehr haben darf ich das einmal
das ist ja nix die alte leute diese
ganzen was sie da alles von einem wollen
dass ich ja was suchen sie denn gucken
was hatten sie eben in der hand und so
habe ich die sozialarbeiterin vermutet
dass die 62 jährige an einer schnell
fortschreitenden früh demenz erkrankt
ist angehörige hat sie nicht nur einen
hilfsbereiten nachbarn
er schaut seit monaten immer wieder nach
er inzwischen aber ist er mit der
situation überfordert
wir suchen das gleich mit ich helfe
ihnen gleich mit suchen konnte noch
einen augenblicken ist sich zu uns
setzen
sabine bürger will vermeiden dass die
seniorin in ein pflegeheim muss nicht
drum herum kommen tatsächlich einen
betreuer zu brauchen
der ist dafür da sie zu unterstützen ich
weiß ja nicht ob ich mit ihm zustehen ok
das ist ja das müsste passen
das heißt aber auch zu garantieren sie
bleiben hier sie kriegen ihr die
unterstützung sie haben natürlich auch
verfügung über ihr geld da spricht eben
keiner rein
die selbstbestimmtheit im alter
aufzugeben fällt schwer weiß die
sozialarbeiterin
deshalb versucht sie alles damit alte
menschen möglichst lange in ihrer
eigenen wohnung leben können und weiter
geht die suche nach dem portemonnaie
temperaturen nach draußen läuft und den
weg nach hause nicht mehr findet dann
ist sie existenziell gefährdet und
spätestens bei diesen journal situation
muss geguckt werden geht es noch zu
hause
da kommen sie erst einmal essen
die senioren vergisst häufig zu essen
sie wiegt nur noch 39 kilo
sabine bürger muss jetzt schnell einen
pflegedienst und einen gesetzlichen
betreuer organisieren
ich versuche gefahren zu minimieren und
so klein wie möglich zu halten aber ich
kann nicht das leben komplett
kontrolliert kann immer was passieren so
dass nur sie akzeptieren als ich so
angefangen habe war das sicherlich so
einem punkt wo so manche nacht nicht gut
geschlafen habe das passiert nur dass
man dinge nahe gehen dass ich dann auch
nach tatsächlich mal aufwachen und dann
weiß ich spätestens jetzt musst du
handeln weil jetzt hast du kein gutes
gefühl und auf mein gefühl kann ich mich
eigentlich gut verlassen um halb acht
hole ich sie ab geben wir zusammen hin
zum hausarzt morgen halb acht halbakt
bin ich hier im benachbarten
gelsenkirchen hilft pablo marzoll
familien in ihrem leben wieder einen
anker zu finden er ist einer von rund 50
sozialpädagogischen familien helfern in
der stadt
pablo hat soll arbeitet für die diakonie
die im auftrag des jugendamtes tätig ist
erst besuch bei einem
langzeitarbeitslosen alleinerziehenden
vater der ehemalige security-mitarbeiter
hatte vor sechs wochen einen
schlaganfall und braucht unterstützung
bei der erziehung seiner beiden söhne
was wünscht sich der vater vom
sozialpädagogischen familien helfer
doch das war gar keine familie die
beiden muss jeder ein bisschen ruhiger
kriegen und ist ziemlich aufgedreht die
köpfe habe ich kann ja auch schreiben
der top 8 jähriger wegen aufgebot ist
aufgedreht witzig immer die erwachsenen
ja was heißt erwachsene zu nerven hier
hätte es gerne auch das erwachsen was
ich mit euch beschäftigen höre ich da
raus stimmt ja auch
was aber soll nur streng sei wenn wir
wirklich machen sonst keiner liebt sein
ja richtig angestrengt sein möchten
aber ich sehe das alles gut läuft und
was bringt mir das dann vorzustellen
seit fünf jahren bekommt die familie
sozialpädagogische hilfe jetzt hat pablo
hat soll den fall übernommen
im mittelpunkt steht für ihn das wohl
der kinder so wünscht es sich auch der
vater ein wissenschaftliches verfahren
soll helfen soll nutzt die sogenannte
martin methode
sie soll dabei helfen dass das
zusammenleben der familie besser und
respektvoller wird er filmt sie bei
ihrem umgang miteinander und lässt sie
dabei allein der sozialarbeiter ist
selbst vater zweier kinder
es geht ihm darum positive momente
herauszufiltern und später der familie
anhand des films zu zeigen wie
kommunikation am besten
links ich erzähle auch gerne dass die
familie ein großes schiff ist wo es ein
steuerrad gibt und die familie muss sich
einigen wer hat dieses steuerrad und der
hand wer bestimmt den weg und meine
rolle sehe ich eher auf seinem kleinen
lotsenboot hast irgendwie sicher vor
herd und mal der familie sagt er da
vorne ist ein eisberg war nach vorne
kommt ein sturm auf fahren sie mal
lieber ein bisschen in die andere
richtung werdet also mein ratschlag
sabine birke ist blödsinn von bis zu 15
schicksalen gleichzeitig ihren nächsten
klienten betreut sie schon seit vier
monaten den schwer kranken hirn willen
der mit seinem haushalt komplett
überfordert war
vor kurzem hat sie einen
hauswirtschaftlichen dienst organisiert
offenbar mit durchschlagendem erfolg
kann man durch die sozialarbeiterin kann
einen ersten haken auf ihrem hilfeplan
machen
der nächste schritt eine barrierefreie
wohnung für den gehbehinderten mann doch
solche wohnungen sind rar und die
konkurrenz groß auf ein objekt kommen
auf dutzende bewerber am vortag haben
die beiden eine solche wohnung
besichtigt jetzt hilft die
sozialarbeiterin beim
bewerbungsschreiben um seine schmerzen
zu lindern hat herr will meinen großen
wunsch der 66-jährige war sein leben
lang schichtarbeiter bei krupp bis er
krank wurde
in deutschland ist jeder siebte über 65
arm oder von armut gefährdet wenn dann
krankheit und einsamkeit hinzukommen
sind sozialarbeiter wie sabine bürger
befragt
erklärend leidet unter einer unheilbaren
nervenerkrankung sabine beuke möchte
wissen welche medikamente er einnimmt
13 verschiedene sind es täglich darunter
starke morphine gegen seine schmerzen
hat herr will mein gerät implantiert
bekommen
zwei elektroden stimulieren die nerven
erfolgt dann mehr wort probleme zeigen
erste antwort wissen und das bild stellt
meinen hoffen
die hoffnung dass das gerät seine
schmerzen noch eine weile lindert aber
es lässt sich nur noch um eine stufe
höher stellen
herr wilm ist in letzter zeit oft
gestürzt
deshalb begleitet in die
sozialarbeiterin heute zur apotheke um
neue medikamente zu holen
schwer krank und dabei allein zu sein
verstärkt oft ängste beobachtet die
helferin vom sozialamt
am anfang wollte er will nicht einmal
die türe öffnen und erst mal
misstrauisch
das hat sich dann anders noch entwickelt
dass da haben wir uns aneinander heran
gearbeitet so zu sagen so dass das jetzt
wirklich
ein vertrauensvolles verhältnis geworden
ist vertrauen ein schlüsselwort auch für
familienhelfer pablo marzoll in
gelsenkirchen
er ist auf dem weg zu einer allein
erziehenden jungen mutter bei ihr geht
es um das wohl des kindes
seit einem halben jahr kommt er bis zu
dreimal pro woche vorbei auch mal
unangekündigt das jugendamt hat die
hilfe angeordnet er kontrolliert wie es
im haushalt läuft
für alles gibt es beurteilungen auch sie
muss sich selbst einschätzen
beim haushalt gibt sich die junge mutter
inzwischen aber beim thema
kindersicherheit hat der familienhelfer
immer noch große sorge so hat er auch
schon mal eine zigarettenkippe im mund
des kindes gefunden eine tödliche gefahr
für ein kleinkind
die fensterbänke kinder ist es manchmal
einfacher einfach die vasen von der
fahrbahn zu lange weg zu stellen wo sie
alles abruft und alles immer in
nimmt ist diese phase vorbei ist nicht
gut das ist aber wichtiger für sie dann
und im moment nicht gut aussieht als das
ist vielleicht für ihre tochter
einfacher ist nicht so auf das nein zu
hören wenn die frau nicht besser auf ihr
kind aufpasst schickt das jugendamt sie
in eine mutter-kind-einrichtung die
frage ist nun macht sich freiwillig mit
da geht es ja darum falls das jugendamt
entschließt es weiterhin eine gefährdung
und dann nehme ich da ein stück an ihren
überlegungen teilhaben lassen was da so
ihre überlegung zu sind doch diese zeit
will er das jugendamt nicht mehr geben
seit monaten lähmt sie viele von pablo
matzerath schlägen ab noch am selben tag
wird das jugendamt auf empfehlung des
sozialarbeiters entscheiden ambulante
familienhilfe reicht nicht mehr aus
die junge frau muss mit ihrer tochter in
eine betreuende einrichtung ziehen
ja das ist durchaus möglich wird oder
sichtbaren es möglicherweise von links
die die kein kein problembewusstsein
irgendwie haben die sah das ist alles in
ordnung so wie es ist oder auch wenn es
einfach auch gar kein veränderungswille
innerhalb der familie gibt dann ist es
einfach mühselig manchmal mit dem mit
dem kleinen teelöffel an der großen
betonwand irgendwie so zu kratzen und
keine großen schritte machen zu können
das fordert auch viel viel geduld
natürlich
zurück in bochum sabine beuke begleitet
heute die vergessliche seniorin zum
neurologen die diagnose eilt denn die
sozialarbeiterin hat festgestellt dass
die alte dame seit drei monaten keine
erwerbsunfähigkeitsrente mehr erhält
wegen eines fehlenden ärztlichen attests
und auch für den antrag auf gesetzliche
betreuung braucht sabine beuke dringend
einen schriftlichen befund ein schwerer
moment für die patienten
heute bekommt sie klarheit über ihren
gesundheitlichen zustand
nach einer ausführlichen untersuchung
stellt der arzt seine diagnose demenz
mit schnellem verlauf sowie von sabine
beuke befürchtet
aus vielen jahren erfahrung in der
altenhilfe weiß die sozialarbeiterin ein
solcher befund führt oft in die
verzweiflung
besonders wenn man ganz allein ist
das gedächtnis der senioren wird rapide
schwinden
ich kann mich nicht völlig abgrenzen von
dem was ich mit menschen erlebe wie sie
lassen mich auch in ihre lebenssituation
rein da muss ich mich auch darauf
einlassen können
aber ich darf mich nie so tief fallen
lassen ist sich handlungsunfähig werde
weil ich von ähnlichen gefühlen geleitet
werde
da muss ich achten dass ich mir in einem
wildesten aufrechterhalten kann das ist
schon auch wichtig
[Musik]
auch pablo marzoll muss in seinem beruf
emotional einiges aushalten
vor kurzem kam ein 14 jähriger junge den
er über monate begleitet hatte auf
dramatische weise ums leben
der jugendliche inhalierte deospray um
sich zu betäuben und erstickte daran
ich war erstmal total geschockt ich habe
schon so ganz weiche knie gekriegt und
war ganz ganz komisch zumute als ich das
gehört habe und irgendwie so ansatzweise
realisiert habe das ist tatsächlich
alles
anfangs wusste pablo matzel nicht dass
es ein unfall war
in quälte die frage ob er warnzeichen
übersehen hatte
die nachricht von seinem tod war quasi
kurz vor der geburt bei der tochter ali
ist drei tage später nachdem ich das
erfahren hatte geworden und das hat mir
noch mal sehr eindrücklich auch gezeigt
wie nah leben und tod dann noch beim
berlin-besuch bei einer
alleinerziehenden mutter mit vier
kindern
ihre beiden älteren töchter sind zurzeit
in einem heim untergebracht auch deshalb
weil die mutter mit der erziehung
überfordert war
heute geht es um die selbsteinschätzung
der mutter wie stark hat sich ihre
erziehungskompetenz nach sechs monaten
familienhilfe verbessert die frau kämpft
sie möchte das jugendamt davon
überzeugen wieder alle vier kinder bei
ihr wohnen zu lassen und sie hat schon
gute fortschritte gemacht meint pablo
marzoll
heute sind hartnäckig wenn ich jetzt
noch mal überlegen möchte was wie sieht
denn die die 85 zum beispiel aus dass
unter die neuen wenn man jetzt den
nächsten kleinen schritt nimmt ja da
kann ihn noch gesehen wie gut meine ich
bin schon sehr konsequent geworden wenn
ich sag nein nein und dann ist es so zu
machen
die mutter sagt sie sei dankbar für die
hilfe des sozialarbeiters und sie
vertraue ihm durch ihn hat sie gelernt
erziehungs regeln umzusetzen
[Musik]
ihr herzenswunsch ist leicht zu erraten
dass ich irgendwann mal wieder meine
mädchen in den arm nehmen kann das war
einfach nur glücklich zusammen leben
können so wie sich das gehört
nicht zu
doch nichts kann uns trennen er will
etwas sinnvolles tun für andere menschen
aus diesem grund hat pablo maz all
seinen beruf gewählt
auch wenn sozialarbeiter zu den am
schlechtesten bezahlten akademischen
berufen gehört und die belastung hoch
ist dass ich da auch gedanken natürlich
mit nach hause nehmen und hätte ich da
noch was anderes sagen sollen hätte ich
da was anderes machen können das
durchaus auch in meiner freizeit
beschäftigt momentan betreut pablo
marzoll acht familien
zwei davon hat er von einer erkrankten
kollegen übernommen
die personaldecke der sozialarbeiter
schrumpft experten schätzen auf 500
freie stellen kommen nur 100 bewerbern
auch im seniorenbüro in bochum stapelt
sich die arbeit nach ihren hausbesuchen
muss sabine beuke protokolle schreiben
und die hilfen für die alten menschen
organisieren
sie ist für die hausbesuche in fünf
stadtteilen alleinverantwortlich dazu
kommen oft unangekündigte besuche in
ihrem büro frau sander krieg hat schaut
seit einigen wochen häufig vorbei die 83
jährige ist nach dem plötzlichen tod
ihres mannes komplett überfordert er
hatte sich um den papierkram gekümmert
zum beispiel die offenen rechnungen
ich weiß nicht wo sie hingelegt habe ich
find's nicht hat alles nachgesehen das
ist das was ich mir notiert habe
folgewoche das ist ja eine
banküberweisung ist schon zuviel für die
alte dame habe ich das zu bezahlen
ich habe schon mal so eine große schrift
und ich finde es nicht drauf
es sind ja nicht ein kästchen wanne und
die hand die haben so eine lange lung
sabine bürger hat vieles für frau sander
cricket in die hand genommen zum
beispiel den antrag auf witwenrente den
verlust hat die alte dame noch nicht
verarbeitet
das fällt mir so schwer man liegt
alleine im bett da ist neben ein
gestorben und das ist das schwere leben
ich bin wochen lang auf ihrem sofa
gelegen ich konnte mich im bett schlafen
ist ganz schwer
neben mir war kalt wie ich morgens sagt
gerd wie geht ja denn heute und so
weiter ich war so an
nein diesen moment möchte ich nicht noch
mal erleben
das war ganz schwer
[Musik]
die allermeisten brauchen gesellschaft
und brauchen menschen die ihnen wichtig
sind und die meisten die in einsamen
leben ist es keine selbstgewählte
einsamkeit sondern es ist eine
einsamkeit die über sie kommt mit denen
sie auch nicht zurecht kommen die auch
krank macht die sie manchmal böse werden
lässt oder misstrauisch werden lässt und
dass das ist etwas was ich zutiefst
bedauern zu hause bei sabine bürger seit
elf monaten ist die großmutter der
kleinen leila
sie ist verheiratet mit einem gebürtigen
palästinenser und hat zwei erwachsene
kinder
ehemann sade hat heute arabisch gekocht
er arbeitet als streetworker für das
jugendamt auch tochter nadja ist
sozialarbeiterin das gemeinsame
abendessen ein wichtiges familien ritual
dass ich da eine ganz exklusive
situation zurzeit habe gesund familie
arbeit also für mich sind halten die
beziehung das was das leben lebenswert
macht und auch in vielen bereichen auch
erträglich macht weil es ist ja nicht
nur einfach und dass man kommt immer
wieder auch an grenzen
ohne meine leute um mich herum wer das
alles nichts ahnung hat soll zurück beim
alleinerziehenden vater der
sozialarbeiter zeigt heute das
ausgewertete filmmaterial
er hat für die familie die positiven
momente heraus gesucht die sich beim
gemeinsamen spiel ergeben haben
der vater und seine söhne sollen spüren
wie wichtig selbst kleine gesten und
worte für den zusammenhalt sind
da haben alle gleichzeitig gelacht
das ist ein so ein bild was sich was ich
raus geschnitten habe wo es einfach noch
einmal deutlich wird wie viel wie viel
spaß hier zusammen haben sie viel freude
auch
[Musik]
sehen sie dass ihre kinder zu ihnen auf
gruppen und mit ihren augen an ihren
lippen hängen was sagt der papa jetzt
als nächstes sohn und ja sie haben die
volle aufmerksamkeit ihrer söhne ist
auch ein schönes bild sowie einem großen
starken papa an kuschelt
die erkenntnis es geht auch ganz ohne
streit
[Musik]
pablo maz arbeit trägt erste früchte
janneke vermutet und wieder noch stärker
an zu machen welcher see baut wieder ein
bisschen mehr auf ein motivationsschub
auch für den sozialarbeiter so ganz
explizit gesagt wird danke herbert soll
toll dass sie jetzt irgendwie so da war
passiert nicht ganz so oft aber wenn ich
so ein feedback bekommen dass es
irgendwie nützlich war was ich den
familien anbieten konnte ich freue ich
mich natürlich und ja das macht mich
auch glücklich und auch ein stück stolz
auch für alten helferin sabine burger
schliesst sich ein kapitel ihrer arbeit
für die früh demente dame hat sie einen
pflegedienst organisiert auch die rente
fließt wieder regelmäßig
und ich merke auch es scheint ihnen
wasser zu gehen ja naja wenn man es wenn
so leute sich um einen kümmern dann ist
man ja irgendwie das schlimmste ich ja
wenn man keinen hat genau und kann mir
kommt und man ist mit dem problem allein
und kann bisher nicht loswerden das
haben sie ja eine gesetzliche betreuerin
die ihnen bei all diesen dingen hilft
dann werde ich das kenne ich die ja sie
ich hab sie ihn vorgestellt wir haben
hier schon mal zu dritt zusammen
gesessen so dass ich mich so langsam
aber sicher so ein bisschen raus ziehen
kann und auch aussehen werde
ja sie haben wir jetzt eine ganze menge
an leuten die sie unterstützen und ich
muss mich jetzt um die leute mehr
kümmern die genau solche leute nicht
haben und einsame menschen gibt es immer
mehr
nicht nur in bochum
[Musik]
es ist schon das wofür ich dann auch
gerne arbeite wo ich dann zufrieden bin
und sagen kann ja da scheint es ja alles
richtig gemacht zu haben alles gut so so
kann ich gut mich zum nächsten fall
begeben sozusagen
[Musik]
facebook